farmer's daughter take one
i need to be famous wayne
all the best people are ain't nobody
else out there like you
you know why
why
because you got that x factor
that days of struggling may soon be over
hollywood here we go
this is it our own studio background
i'm looking for a place to stay
oh yes sir
that's one of this home [ __ ]
and my wife pearl was next door so i
would appreciate a little discretion
you don't know what we're doing does he
well it's better to beg for forgiveness
and ask for permission
would you like to
come
inside how much advice
i want to be in the movie well you can't
the story can't just change midway
through
if daddy catches us
there's no telling what he might do
my wife is not well
it happens after darkness
[Music]
you don't want to leave do you people's
eyes are gonna pop out of their damn
skulls when i see this
what
are you all right
now
[Music]
oh boy spam this inside what do you
think is on it
i see one goddamn [ __ ] up horror
picture